my name is Ephraim it originated from
Somalia but I come from Island I'm Irish
citizen I'm a survivor of FGM I was
second side twice I decided to work with
young people to educate about FGM and I
set up united Europe Island so we can
educate one another about female genital
mutilation professionals need to know
more about FGM so they can protect women
my medical checkup wasn't easy I
remember first time when I come to
Ireland I was asked about FGM wasps and
I have to go and the medical check-up
and the nurses did not understand where
I come from and what I was talking about
I was asking how I got injured and that
really shocked me and I have to explain
say this is my culture practice and they
say why is the necessary day to do it if
the family they come in Europe and they
really have to understand what is the
legality of Europe so if the young
person go to school and they educate
well then she can go back to her home
and explain her family that FGM is an
issue on is it illegal to do it in the
practice and also it's important bring
in the family and to understand that you
are not accepting female genital
mutilation
you